the national atomic testing museum held
a breakfast and panel discussion today
to commemorate the 60th anniversary of
the sedan nuclear test jeremy j ford
spoke with visitors and panelists about
their their experiences and he joins us
live in the newsroom tonight with the
latest jeremy
well thanks sasha just 65 miles
northwest of las vegas is the home of a
former nuclear weapons testing site
visitors showed up to the atomic testing
museum to learn more about what happened
there 60 years ago
on july the 6th 1962 the united states
conducted the sedan nuclear test the
goal of the explosion was to determine
how practical nuclear detonations are
for excavating large amounts of earth it
was part of a program called project
plowshare where they were looking for
peaceful uses of nuclear weapons and
plowshare was going to be
seen if it could be used for digging out
harbors or another panama canal if you
will but due to post radiation in the
atmosphere eventually all testing
projects were scrapped leaving a large
crater in the desert and a useful
learning experience this was a complete
success but the united states was still
going on with its developmental program
for nuclear weapons to assure the safety
reliability of the nuclear weapons if we
had to use them this month marks the
60-year anniversary of the formation of
the crater on saturday the national
atomic testing museum hosted a round
table discussion guests were invited to
learn more about one of the most iconic
blasts in atomic testing history and the
largest man-made crater in the united
states that formed as a result i think
the atomic bombs are
cool i learned some stuff like they had
to like stay away from it if they didn't
want to get radiation
on them
well back in 1994 the sedan crater was
officially added to the national
register of historic places and today
you can tour the site we have a link to
the register on our website eight news
now
dot com from the newsroom jeremy j ford
live local now